okay um hi everyone my name is josh earl
i'm an assistant professor at drexel
university i work in the
department of immunology and
microbiology
and i'm going to be talking to you a
little bit about using machine learning
in predicting clinical provenance in
hemophilus influenza
so hamacho's influenza is an important
bug
it's a bacteria it's one of the leading
causes of otitis medium which is a
middle ear infection
um the incidence worldwide is about uh
700 million uh children like young
children per year
uh it costs about 10 million dollars in
surgeries per year in the us
and sort of overall costs are around
like four to five billion
uh per year in the us uh some of the
repercussions are like it's one of the
most common causes of
of hearing loss in children um so like
more than 300 per hundred thousand
and this can result in a bunch of
different things uh deficits in
in like a child's ability to learn
speech and language and perform in
school
and and interact with others so it's an
important
uh pathogen to kind of understand um the
other thing that we really have to talk
about
in order to sort of understand a lot of
what's coming next is
is like the the evolution of homophonic
influenza
um so homophobic influenza is what's
called a naturally competent bacteria
which means that it can take dna from
the exogenous
environment that it's in and then
actually recombine that dna
into its own genome
and so what this means is that
not like traditionally what happens is
is that we all inherit our genetic
material from our appearance
so we call this like vertical descent
right uh vertical inheritance of dna
from from our
ancestors um but homophilus itself is a
strain of bacteria that can actually
like
um sidestep that and and end up taking
um dna if the conditions are right
taking dna from its environment or from
other
you know uh bacteria that are nearby or
other organisms
and actually recombine that into its own
dna which changes the genetic structure
of the genome um in these strains itself
um and so some of the examples might be
like you know an organism
is particularly fit to exist in some
type of environment
but then it can acquire genetic material
which which gives it a selective
advantage
in a different environment and so that's
actually going to be pretty important
for us
in the upcoming slides because we're
going to be using that information to
try to figure out if there's something
about the genetics itself
that predisposes some strains to live in
certain environments over others
um so in order to facilitate doing this
we
uh our labs and others have actually
sequenced whole genome sequence to 100
or 1618 genomes of homophobic influenza
um and so you know we downloaded
probably a quarter of the streams from
the internet from pnas and
ncbi but we have also partnered with
several other labs in order to get
clinical strains
um in order to do the whole genome
sequencing on them and this slide just
sort of shows you some of the
um the types of
filters that we use in order to identify
what a good assembly um
actually was and so we started we we
sequence actually even more than this
but we
we only use the best sequences that we
could we could get our hands on
so um this is sort of like the
the meat a little bit i guess of like
what we're going to be trying to predict
um so out of our approximately 1600
genomes
um we have labels we have which is
really great for analysis
is that we actually have these these
metadata these categories that are
assigned
to each one of these different genomes
and what this means is that
um you know a genome that
was is labeled as carriage means that it
was
isolated from a person who
did not have symptoms and you know it
wasn't showing any
any sort of disease type um and so these
are these are sort of like
in a in a commensal state and then we
have
um the ear eye invasive and lung
categories which are all different
um uh locations in which
a strain was isolated from
so this would be things like
um conjunctivitis for example if it was
coming from the eye
middle ear infections if it was coming
from the ear copd from the lung
invasive is like um if there was a
bacteremia or something that was
isolated from the blood for example
um two of the categories that we have so
you know some of the strands we just
don't know what their their providence
was due to you know the lack of labeling
and then there were several that were
hard to fit into these like categories
that we created those are the others and
so we have to sort of ignore those when
we're doing this classification strategy
and you know something that we're going
to talk about a lot is this idea of
class imbalance and how that's
problematic when it comes to doing
machine learning algorithms
and so maybe we should be ignoring some
of these other categories in here where
we have
like fewer strains um
so you know talking about
uh the fact that tomorrow's influenza is
a is a naturally competent species
um what we wanted to do like initially
is just be like okay well maybe
the you know these organisms are just
their overall phylogenetic signal you
know
presuppose that they're they're going to
belong to one of these categories
already in which case
it wouldn't really make any sense to do
sort of machine learning because we
could just use the phylogenetic signal
and say oh okay
you know these are you know the reason
that they they live in the ears because
like everything in this plane lives in
an ear and like and
you know the ear strains don't exist in
other phylogenetic
plates but that isn't the case actually
if we look at this
and look at the you know sort of this
example played we can see a broad
distribution
of the um the different categories
amongst various different clades
and there's no one like phylogenetic
signal that that
can explain why a strain might be living
in an ear or
why it might be living in an eye um
like you know necessarily and like this
example you can see that there's a
there's a broad
um distribution like even within a
single plane
so this is actually a good problem for
machine learning because machine
learning can tease out
um like underlying importance in the
data set
um that may not be obvious by other
methods
uh okay so just to talk a little bit
about the the genomics here so
each strain after we've um sequenced
each string we then annotate like whole
genome sequence we then annotate with a
program called proca
uh which just goes through and attempts
to identify all of the different gene
sequences that exist
in that string um and so for
for us what we're interested in is being
able to sort of like cluster those genes
together so that we can say hey
these genes are are the same and
probably have the same function
based on the fact that they're very
similar in
their their nuclear their nucleotide or
amino acid context
so here we're saying they have to be 70
identical in amino acid content and then
we say they're all part of the same
um gene cluster and so in this
this little table you can see um we have
strains that are are composed
of these different presence and absences
of various different gene clusters and
so
the columns in here are the the genes um
you know presence in absence and the
rows are the strains
and then finally what we're what we're
really hoping to do is we're hoping that
we can use machine learning to
to categorize each of these different
strains
into the different categories that they
belong to
um and we'll we'll talk a little bit
more maybe like
about the um sort of intuition about why
we want to do that here in the next few
slides but
this is uh this slide shows you sort of
like
a heat map which is just exactly the
data that i was talking about
previously except that it's been rotated
so now strains would be
each column in this figure and then the
gene clusters would be the different
roads
and you can see like the light blue
cluster type
on the the um the edge of the heat map
there
it those indicate whether or not they
are core and core genes just mean
whether or not they're present
in every single string and if it's not
core then it's present in some
subset of those strains um and
initially what we're going to be doing
is we're going to be looking at
uh how uh about the ones that are not
core because more than half of these
genes are not core right
and so maybe we can actually predict um
what area of the body or or whether
it was a carrot strain or not based on
the presence
of those different genes so we have to
do some filtering um on this data
uh and the reason is is because some of
these these genes are not actually very
informative when it comes to trying to
to differentiate of one stream from
another and so one category
where they're not informative are core
genes right because every single strain
has them and so it doesn't
it doesn't give us any any information
when it comes to
trying to you know differentiate one
strain from the other and the other
category that doesn't really add very
much is
the um the the genes which exist
only in a single strain or only in one
or two strands
uh those don't actually give us a lot of
differentiating power when we're talking
about
sixteen hundred different possible um
strains here so so
we're like um the the graph that's on
the
um on the left here that that is like
the initial distribution of all the g's
and the one on the right is sort of like
the middle distribution
after we've filtered out the core and
and very
rare genes and and that brings us down
to about 794 different keys that we're
going to try to
use as gene features in our machine
learning
um okay so so the here's the
why would we want to do this right i
mean uh
presumably if if someone is in a
clinical environment
and they isolate a strain of homophobic
influenza it's very likely that they
already know
where it is that they've isolated this
strain from right
and so like building a classifier to
give an unknown genome
and and tell us where that that strain
is from
um is not necessarily like the most
important reason to build a classifier
like this what's really important is
that we want to be able to figure out
what the gene content is that
differentiates
those different bugs from those
different categories
and this can lead us to you know have
different novel treatments for these
different
um uh different strains of bacteria that
are associated
with different places on the human body
um and so i didn't actually talk about
this very much
you know previously but these are all of
these strains are non-type-able
haemophilus influenza
and in the past um people have used the
the polysaccharide coat on the outside
of a hemophilus influenza in order to
create vaccines and
you know like you know boost immunity
against those specific types because
they have very obvious targets on the
outside of the cell
and so since these are non-type-able
influenza it's harder to do that with
and so we're
we're hoping that we can get some
insight into these genes
to be able to um uh
actually identify important fearless
factors and
um you know new treatments and different
gene annotations
and so one of the reasons that we have
to worry about
gene annotation is so this is this is a
word cloud of
all the different annotate the words in
the annotations
gene annotations that were assigned to
more accelerace which is another
bacteria
um you know one of the top three
bacteria that's involved in middle ear
infections which are lab studies a lot
but
but essentially like this this graph is
very similar if you're looking at a more
excellent
or uh you know strep pneumonia or you
know homophobic influenza you know
we get a very similar profile to this
and you'll notice that the number one
annotation to a gene that we've got
is this hypothetical right in the middle
there this big guy
and so what that means is basically
every time that we try to annotate one
of these genomes
we do not know the function
of most of the genes that exist in these
genomes i mean it's it's hard to
to tease that out in the in a lab it
takes work and you know and having
someone dedicated to it and so
having these computational methods for
us to be able to
assign some kind of meaning to two
different genes is actually pretty
important
um you know and so this is kind of what
we're referring to when we're talking
about like the genomic dark matter
all right so i'm gonna i'm gonna talk a
little bit i'm not gonna go into tons of
detail about this but just to give you
guys some intuition about the algorithms
that we're using
um you know we'll do a quick history
lesson about how you can use decision
trees
in order to classify different um
different observations here right so
so the way that we're modeling this if
we're using a decision trees we can say
okay you know let's pick some feature
and and in
in our example it's going to be a gene
presence and absence
let's pick a gene that like best
splits our you know all of our strains
into two separate groups
um and so the next step in the algorithm
is have we
solved the problem have we perfectly
split every you know and assign a
classification to everything
um and if we haven't like we still have
mixed classes and those strains that
you know after we've made that decision
then we go to the next level and we'll
take another gene
that best splits either the ones that
had the previous team or the ones that
didn't have the previous game
again in the in the way that we can
split them in the most
even possible manner and essentially we
just keep doing this
until we reach our maximum depth of the
tree that we decided we want
or we have been able to classify
everything like every
branch in that tree has a perfect
classification but only a single class
um so this is this is a this is a great
idea it's a it's a great first step it's
very
very simple and easy to understand and
also very fast
well my problem is very sensitive to
noise and variance and you can very
easily
pick the wrong um genes to split on a
natural
initially and just like increase
the the confusion of the the classifier
more than the
the accuracy itself um so the next
uh uh like iteration of this is like
okay well
you know one just one decision tree is
good then maybe
um if we use a bunch of them we can get
a better result
and that's basically the idea of random
forests is that essentially what we do
is instead of using the entire data set
and only building a single tree out of
that to take
subsets of our genes and build lots and
lots of
you know mini trees you know each one
that can give a classification
um you know of a different genome
a different strain and then what we're
going to do is we're just going to like
build a ton of them and take majority
rule um
and so this is this is sort of nice
because it gives us properties
that allow us to do things like decide
what
genes are actually the most important
for classifying
um different strains and and ones that
are
you know specifically important for
particular classes and and that sort of
thing is very
it's a robust method it was sort of king
of a lot of machine learning
competitions for years
um but that was recently uh
kind of overtaken by this next method
which
which is a boosting method so all right
you know if
more trees are good um then
you know that that's that increases our
our ability to classify
correctly well but are all trees that
good
and so what the boosting methods do is
they they um
they again are building a lot of
different trees so it's a very similar
algorithm to the random forest
um but this time what we're going to do
is we're going to make decisions about
the trees that were made
and ones that classify poorly
in our training data set we're actually
not going to listen to them as much
um in the the final classification of
our
our um uh strain um and so
so in this way it actually can increase
the the accuracy because it reduces
the um
the the poorly performing trees and the
influence that they have in the final
classification method
and of course xg boost is sort of the
king of this is like the problem with
that
method is that it slowed the random
force down quite a bit
um but with xt boost there's a bunch of
different optimizations that
happened in the background specifically
uh doing things like parallelization and
memory optimizations which will
make it very very fast in fact even
faster than uh
traditional random forest
implementations
um so just a little bit about how i did
this for people who are familiar with
machine learning i want to
you know check this it's what i did is
an 80 20 testing split so that means
that i'm
training these models on 80 of the data
um
and i'm leaving out 20 uh of the data as
as to use as like a a check um
so like the models have never seen this
data before and i'm gonna see
how well training these models can can
classify these strains that they've
never seen before
um and so like it's also with uh
five-fold cross validation which we
repeated twice and i implemented it in
our care
uh okay so results all right how are we
doing
um so just using random forests
uh in order to classify this and and the
way that you read this
this little figure here this little
table is
the car the true class right so
everything
should be you know in that column it
should be
whatever is labeled at the top so in the
first column there
every strain is actually a carriage
strain that we have labeled
and you can see um every row on the side
is what was predicted that that strain
like those strains
were um so you can see that 67 of our
carry strains we're classified as
carriage
um and then like the next uh
row down there in the carriage column
you can see like five percent of ear
strains were
classified as carriage um etc etc
and so we can see here like that um
we were pretty good at classifying both
carriage
and lung strains as carriage and mom
and this is not too surprising to us
because of that class imbalance reason
that we were talking about before
um you'll notice that along that top row
there
most of the most of the time when
it's a a different class than carriage
um like the ear eye and invasive when
it's a different class than carriage and
lung
most often the mistakes that we're
making are get drawn into that large
class
and the reason for that is that the
you know the because of this underlying
imbalance
um when there's a guest that has to be
made
it more often guesses that is part of
one of these larger classes
because just by you know statistical
reasoning you would be
you know more often correct if you know
if that was a true
representation of the population in the
world
but it's not so so this is this is a
this is a problem
in a perfect world on the diagonal we
would have a hundred percent because
every
everything that was truly in here would
be truly classified
as a year you know et cetera et cetera
but we get about 55
and that that might not seem great but
it's way better
than if we were just randomly assigning
these based on their their
their um class frequency uh which would
be
around 32 percent and so there's
definitely information in there
um that that's allowing us to get a
better classification than random
all right so what happens if we use um
xg
so we get better right so our class
accuracy goes up to um
about 60 you know 60 a little
a little over 60 percent there um we're
still having trouble with those
um imbalanced classes right so again you
can see
more often than not if there's a mistake
being made
it's assigning the mistaken genome to
one of the large classes the either the
lung or the carriage class
and less often to the er eye and
invasive class
um okay so that's that's good so um
can we do a little bit better all right
so there's actually some different
parameters that we can modify
um for these different algorithms uh
random forest has a
has a couple of different ones mainly
it's just the depth of the tree like how
how many games you allow to begin a tree
um or like the gene layers in a tree um
and also like just the total number of
trees that
are created from randomly sampling from
your
your
data set um has a bunch more different
parameters you can modify i kind of
focused on like the
um the learning rate so how like the
amount of modification that's um
that happens whenever sg boost is trying
to make some decision about
you know how to to weight things um
how deep the the number of layers that
you want in your tree
and you know your optimization rounds
and those are the ones that i sort of
focused on here
so we did a little uh optimization
parameter search space
i'm looking at a variety of different
numbers of rounds
i'm changing the learning rate you know
it defaults to 0.3
but i wanted to kind of look at you know
what happened if we if we
let it learn a little slower and so like
when it saw something mistaken
it didn't like buy into that so strongly
um to begin with um you know allowing it
to sort of like more slowly decide
what were important variables um and
then like
looking at what the tree depth was so
like the number of different genes that
we would include
when we're we're building our our
decision trees
um and so you can see from here like
actually it looks like
um you know like the
the learning rate of 0.3 this middle
graph here would be way better if we
were
much lower than that in fact like i
might even
you know continue to go a little bit
lower and one of the problems with doing
this
this parameter search space is that it's
hard to
change different parameters and then
make decisions about them
um without fixing other ones and so this
is something i'm going to talk a little
bit about what we're going to do in the
future but
but at least it certainly looks like
reducing the learning
rate to be a little slower was was
advantageous
um also increasing the um
the number of tree levels
um appears to have like an increase
if we once we get up to 20 basically
there's some diminishing returns
uh but certainly more than six right one
with default
um you know and in the first graph there
like it really doesn't seem to change
very much how how many
rounds of optimizations we do in fact it
almost looks like uh
we might be doing worse if we do too
many of them
um so yeah so we changed
i changed it and did we do any better
and the answer is yeah kind of
i'm not not tons better um you know
basically our carriage gets a little
better
um and there and there's some movements
in the the class distribution class
uh predictions but but doing tons better
isn't
uh you know isn't isn't what i
i found here and part of that i think is
is due to the way that we did the search
or i did the the search in that space
and i think that we can do a better job
with that but
the whole reason we did this right is to
identify some important genes
and and we were able to do that so um
after
uh building these models we were able to
identify like the top 20 most
influential genes and what's really
interesting about this
is again we get some things that we sort
of maybe expect to see there so like for
example there's
there's a beta lactamase which is uh
protection against antibiotics
but there's a bunch of hypothetical
proteins and unknown proteins the
approaches of unknown function
and so that you know is is sort of
exactly what we want to see we want to
see these
um these this unknown biology and
ascribe some meaning to that
okay so the next strategy that we can
use and i'm going to have to kind of go
through this pretty quickly but um
we're leaving out a ton of information
right like we don't use the core genes
at all
um and so core genes are are ones that
exist in
in all of the different strains and
maybe there's some information in that
like
the genotype of them themselves that we
could
that would also be very important for us
to know about
um so but the problem is with using core
genes is that it's really difficult to
compare
very different genes um you know
normally what we do is we look at them
in alignment space but in order to get a
good alignment they have to share a
bunch of homology so you can't just
compare
one gene that's vastly different to
another gene so for example here
um you know in this in this top part
here we've got two very different genes
and the dark blue lines are just places
where they have exactly the same amino
acids
but basically this just means that
they're from the same alphabet they
don't actually have
a lot of relation so we need some way of
um comparing very different genes with
very different lengths and very
different identities to each other
in some functional space um and so
you can see like in in this bottom here
that we've got these two different very
different genes if we could translate
that
into a vector of numbers that meant
something in their functional space
then it would be we would be able to
devise some function of being able to
compare those
those two together and so it just so
happens that dr dampier who is also part
of this
um conference and has a talk i think
uh right before mine also about uh deep
learning he
created a method for us of transforming
these proteins into
vector space so that we could compare
any any
um coupling of proteins that we wanted
um and i won't
talk very much about that at all i like
i encourage you to go check out his talk
and see to learn some more about the
underpinnings of that process
but what we find is if we take you know
200 of the
the core genes and then
we use their vectors to create a
two-dimensional
uh plot like this so this is a t-sne
plot um
which is just like a pca plot or an nmds
or
you know what have you it's taking a
high dimensional thing and collapsing it
down into two dimensions
you can see very good grouping of the
different
genes next to each other and and i've
labeled them with our own
predictions of what cluster they belong
to and so
so what this means is that that dr
dampier's method
is capturing the underlying biology so
even though it's
it's going to a vector of numbers and
it's hard to say like what
each individual number means um it is
capturing something in functional space
that
that groups things that are similar to
each other
so i use those um vectors in order to
run
a couple new or you know another
um iteration of the xg boost algorithm
this time using the summary of those
vectors so like the sum
the mean and max of them and i said can
we predict
the results um from those as features
instead of using just gene presence or
absence
and we actually do better we do better
than we were able to do with the
distributed genes
um you know so we're up to you know
around 61
again way better than you know just
guessing
and uh the
yeah i mean like generally speaking we
actually do much better especially in
the i
class of being able to differentiate um
those apart from the others
and so there's definitely a lot of
information here that we can probably
use
um and again like the whole reason for
doing this is identifying important
genes and we can do that you can see
here that
uh we can identify a group one six one
nine
um many of those summary metrics pop up
in this this these most important
differentiating gene vectors right and
so like that's a
that's a really important group that
that um we'd like to
take a look at um as well as some of
these other ones that i've got colored
arrows by
this is very green data so i can't
really tell you very much about them but
um you know if we reduce the number of
classes like we get rid of some of those
those low um uh fewer
like classes with fewer genomes in them
then we do better we
you know we can get up to like 71 but
that's a little bit of cheating and what
we really like to do is
is do some other strategy of um taking
care of those
those imbalance classes and so um in the
future
obviously like there's a bunch of
different things that we can do here
search the parameter space
for optimal parameters for the different
algorithms
do some kind of fancy imbalance um
you know of classes uh like you know
handle that a little better
um you know do some feature selection
before like get rid of features that are
just not
very informative and and actually just
noise
uh you know examining our misclassified
genomes
and trying to make some decisions about
that uh maybe making some decisions
about phylogenetic signal
the ones that are clustered together and
maybe we want to reduce those
also look at classifying our other and
unknown genomes and just see what we get
and then of course like combine those
two approaches maybe we can make the
granddaddy of all classifiers
and really get a much better prediction
if we use all of the data instead of
just sum up the data
um thank you very much that's the end of
my talk i
i think there's going to be the chance
to send me
questions by email uh thank you very
much to
um the organizers for having me and uh
you know obviously like uh josh mel
jocelyn hammond and rachel ehrlich
both contributed a massive amount to
this
this um this work in their
curation and so
thank you very much and that's the end